foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today is scp-7115
object class
neutralized
special containment procedures
paper records relating to scp-7115 are
currently stored in the Federal Bureau
of Investigations unusual incidence
units secure archive physical remains
relating to scp-7115 are to be stored in
a standard biological containment Locker
per the recommendation of the current
hmcl supervisor of site-187
scp-7115 is presumed to have been
neutralized despite this sightings of
scp-7115a or 7115 1 entities are to be
treated as a high priority threat
description
scp-7115 designates a series of
anomalous phenomena which occurred in
1908 at the Molson and Company meat
packing plant a subsection of the meat
packing District in Chicago the source
of said phenomena is believed to have
been an entity designated
scp-7115-a which at the time operated
under the identity of antanis Remus a
Lithuanian immigrant and employee of the
Molson and Company Plant
addendum 7115 1. background
Molson and company founded in 1863 and
dissolved in 1909 was a pork farming and
packing firm with its largest meat
packing plant located in Chicago's Union
Stockyards the company primarily farmed
and slaughtered Hogs but also
manufactured products such as soap from
slaughterhouse byproducts doing so in
factories adjacent to its main plant
prior to the occurrence of scp-7115 the
president of the company was Henry
Hughes or H.H Molson following the
publication of Upton Sinclair's 1906
novel The Jungle which sought to
advocate for socialism by portraying the
exploitation of immigrants by the
Chicago meat packing industry and
legislative action against the
unsanitary nature of contemporary Meat
Packing Molson grew concerned that
negative publicity legislative action
and unionization would affect his profit
to this end Molson influenced Harold
Leslie the editor of the Chicago Daily
Courier newspaper to publish articles
opposing reform in the Meatpacking
industry this culminated in a letter
from Molson to Leslie undated but likely
sent in August of 1908 suggesting that
Leslie sent a reporter to the Molson
plant disguised as an employee much like
Sinclair himself did in order to
research the jungle with the aim of
producing a first-hand account of the
Meatpacking industry which would present
the most incorporation positively and
contradict Sinclair's book
Leslie recommended Sherman Hayes a young
reporter affluent in a number of the
languages spoken by the immigrant
workers for the task it was to Lodge
with Jelena and Thomas petrulis
employees of Molson and Company who had
previously spied on trade unionists on
behalf of the corporation
addendum 7115 2.
Sherman Hayes Journal
hey stay at the plant from September to
December of 1908 provides the clearest
first-hand account of scp-7115 relevant
excerpts from Hayes notebook and
journals are provided below
the P house or rather Shack is shared
between them and three ragged chickens
which they feed on kitchen scraps
I bunk in the main room by the stove
under the story that I'm a distant
cousin come here to work
they have given me their warmest blanket
I would more happily take it if they did
not go on about how it was the best they
had how they were at the service of the
Molson Corporation and I bowing and
scraping like coolies
to do notes regarding work tomorrow
Street sketches of workers plus area
though less than luxury is the
inhabitants have constructed a
neighborhood brimming with rustic you
know peasant conviviality
praying I will hear some news of
kazovski here
a story that would make my fame though
God only knows if I will gain anything
here except some exotic skin disease
much to praise regarding plant to design
efficiency consult plans for clearer
description when returning to office and
administration
I'm glad to hold a pen after hacking it
Pig carcasses for a day
Foreman was informed regarding my
presence
did not Hound me too hard as he did
other workers even so I'm exhausted Dad
working at half their pace
even with a lighter workload I'm
exhausted a thing I cannot find a kind
of description of is the smell
sweat and flesh piled on flesh and pig
and steam from boiling lards still
clinging to my face
hungry too
so close to pound after pound of meat
with nothing but thin soup for meals not
that I would want pork knowing how the
meat practically steams in its own sweat
and slime for hours
these socialistic voices of the press
May argue for unionization and indolence
but the planned workers actions
demonstrate otherwise
their industriousness is commendable
twice in one day I saw workers cut
themselves butchering the slaughtered
pigs yet grit their teeth manfully and
go on working
well that more in this country had their
grit and sufferance
strange things seen
one man Nikolai lost a finger to an
errant cut
but a wizard worker long prophet's beard
vaguely like Whitman grasped at the
finger and rejoined it to the stump
leaving not even a scar
some parlor trick then
two workers boys were crushed under a
section of the Factory's roof which
caved in this morning
from Gossip seems to have been an event
which has occurred before pillars and
supports widely known to be damaged
previous deaths not reported in The
Courier as far as I know
regrettably not even factories as modern
and well regulated as the Molson plantar
immune to accident
even in grief workers have a rustic
dignity working here I witnessed
Delena says their names were tavas and
writers
Brothers
the old man is called antanis some sort
of Shaman or unofficial leader
better English than all other workers
voice like a preacher
he was consoling Thomas and right as his
mother when Thomas and I arrived to work
word amongst workers as relayed by
Thomas the others do not speak in my
presence that we are to go to a meeting
spot outside workers shanty town tonight
union meeting perhaps
must write down this proof it was all
real
we met in the old man's house
bigger than the rest with a spread of
their country's food laid out
Thomas and I arrived late his wife tired
he was already speaking to the crowd
telling them not to grieve these deaths
nor the other injuries their work had
caused
a masked outcry in the congregation
which showed their injuries furiously
stalks of hands skin peeling from
disease children who were half old
got the stenches they shouted and raped
the old man quieted them
is of no use my friends tears will not
feed or clothe us
does your pain make you want death
I will show you how pain will save you
I thought he was a socialist and was
busy thinking of Words which would best
ridicule his claims when he drew the
boy's mother from the ground
he was sobbing her dress filthy from
working in the fertilizer plant
he produced a knife
the long lightly curd sword used to cut
swine open
you were willing to bleed for Molson
once
now you will bleed for all of us
and with a slash he cut her belly open
top to bottom through the skirt and as
the crowd surged forward and also back
in horror he reached in and parted the
flesh
and out of the bleeding guts pulled
forth a writhing piglet
the crowd quieted as the woman sobbed
quietly still
and he reached in and this time a fat
sow
squealing and thrashing
Trotters Tangled in and kicking her
intestines
was dragged out on the ground
Elizabeth don't cry you bled once for a
rich man now bleed for us all painlessly
and let your blood bring life
and with those words we all fell to and
slaughtered the pigs as we had learned
to do
the workmen are friendlier now having
seen me at that meeting
I was invited to sit with them
even tried their lunch of black bread
and cheese and compared War Stories of
the abuse deform and had made us suffer
they used to look at me with suspicion
then for a moment I rejoiced I was
getting closer to these people
one even told me about how kazowski and
his anarchists were stockpiling dynamite
in this Shanty to play it being gazogas
clouded me around the head and laughing
as if we had worked and shared jokes for
decades
but I know the blood and guts business
which earned me this acceptance
and the taste of raw pork is still slick
on my tongue
the old man must know I do not belong my
face too clean cut
and demeanor too inquisitive
what will I taste like
two men who were friends of Thomas
volunteered to be cut open this time
saying it was better to die to feed
their families than waste away those
workers being Rheumatic from working in
the chilling rooms
shivering even when they stood by the
old man's stove and declared their
willingness
they charged them to bring a third
victim and this night we gathered to see
them kneel besides two others
one of the loaves at Foreman
the other from what gossip in the room
was saying
his son
both tied hand and foot
they jeered them
I cheered with them and cursed the man
and his son too
then spat on the boy's face as we
paraded him through the meeting room and
they were all cut open
and black bristled Hogs rose up out of
their gashed open guts
they feasted on the meat
and the four of them still living crying
and praying as their guts Tangled down
to their knees
were dragged Away by some of the man's
acolytes
plans to do more
others offered themselves as sacrifices
making plans to hunt down others
strangers and beggars
not even the staff at the plant to be
brought as part of the feast
the scream of the boy has a hog twice
his size reared its head from his
stomach and ripped the boy's flank apart
with its tusks
something had nod up the piece chickens
screaming pigs and roaring machines by
day
screaming men and women and children by
night
the old man must know I'm a spy
we are all just meet
these notes were deposited in a PL box
used by Hayes discovered following the
investigation of the events surrounding
the Molson Factory
addendum 7115 3.
scp-7115-1
scp-7115-1 designates a population of
organisms observed in the Meatpacking
District in the autumn and winter of
1908. contemporary autopsies indicate
that recovered corpses were humanoid but
exhibited haphazard and asymmetrical
mutations rendering them superficially
poor seen in appearance while
scp-7115-1 varied visually all specimens
possessed thickened epidermises covered
in bristles elongated faces terminating
in bore-like snouts and teeth elongated
into multiple sets of tusks genetic
testing of recovered skeletal material
indicate that
scp-7115-1 share genetic material with
Baseline Homo sapiens with traces of
sustomesticus susgrofa and matridio
coeris
scp-71151 were reported roaming the
Meatpacking District though signings in
other areas of Chicago were also
recorded usually operating nocturnally
in order to abduct civilians while
records from this period are fragmentary
due to a distrust of law enforcement
amongst the Immigrant population and the
dismissal of sightings as the result of
superstition It is believed that as many
as 50 individuals may have been abducted
in this phase of activity
addendum 7150 18 4. interview
2807 1909
on 15 12 1908 The Irregular threats unit
of the Bureau of Investigation was
notified of a horde of pigs and Pigman
rampaging in Chicago's meat packing
District
reports described hundreds of
scp-71151 instances assaulting civilians
indiscriminately and bisecting their
stomachs with knives or their hands
a combination of non-anomalous swine and
scp-7115-1 instances would then proceed
to emerge from the stomachs of the
victims it is estimated that more than
200 individuals died in this phase of
activity
due to the lack of Manpower and
organization of the then fledgling
Bureau attempts to liaise with the
Chicago police force were haphazard
ultimately the impact of the bureau and
law enforcement on containing the
anomaly was minimal as all
scp-71151 entities and anomalously
produced swine ceased life function in
the morning of 1712 1908 following the
collapse of a section of the roof of the
Molson and Company meat packing plant
the clearest firsthand report of why
this anomalous phenomenon ceased was
provided by Jelena petrulis who was
found unconscious and severely injured
in the ruined Molson Factory and taken
into the bureau's custody following a
lengthy recovery she was permitted to
give her testimony in Lithuanian which
was recorded and translated her
testimony is excerpted below
the company told us to give the boy the
journalist a place in our house or they
would make public the fact that we had
informed on Jack ziemer and Kentucky
with that hanging over our heads we were
hardly concerned with what antanas was
doing
the old man did odd jobs around the
factory
he was not related to any of us
but we all called him grandfather
because he was gentle and a new remedies
for all of our ills how to stretch our
wages or heal a sick child
or more than the ones we lost
I didn't go to the first meeting
I had intended to mourn with them
Elizabethtown was a good friend of mine
but that night I was sick with a fever
when Thomas and the boy came back with
haunches of raw pork in a basket but I
thought I was dreaming
I tasted it and it was the finest
fattiest meat I had eaten
certainly not the worm-ridden stuff the
molson's home
my favorite past 10 days
[Music]
we didn't have the luxury of asking too
many questions
food was always short than the ones who
died
died willingly
the man went to work with a new shine of
Health in their faces and the children
did not go to bed hungry for the first
time in years
then we began hearing that the men were
killing workers who had not chosen to go
to their deaths or strangers or company
staff
there was more meat than ever for all of
us
and then the boy came to me after the
chickens had been mauled to death one
night
he told me that he had hidden his nuts
away in case something happened to him
that night
I will confront him he said in his
stilted school book Lithuanian
I need to understand
or stop it if that is possible
he then apologized if he had caused us
any harm or offense
and said that he had only ever wanted to
help the workers at the plant so
sincerely that I had no choice but to
smile and thank him
there was a godness in his face even
though he like us had grown fat on meat
he vanished that night
Thomas warned me
told me that what had happened to the
boy what happened to me
but I did it
I hit my carving knife in my shawl and
went to the old man's house
he was alone
wrapped in an old fur
cutting slices from a piece of cured
pork fat
my favorite treat when I was young
eaten on bread it drizzled with a few
drops of molasses
but when he offered me it my stomach
turned
and I sat down without speaking
you're afraid aren't you
of my children
who have learned to walk on their hind
legs and forage for their own meals now
he ate
and went on talking
his accent had always been strange
sounding like it was from no place and
every place
I'm sorry about your chickens
you must have been fond of them
when the world was young I preached to
the people of Better Lives but the world
disabused me of that notion
do you know what this country has taught
me it is that all of you can be made to
willingly line up to be chopped up into
meat every belief is just a machine
people go in one end and bodies come out
the other
do you really think that the unions and
the Socialists and the kazuski's
anarchist bombers will save you from
being slaughtered for some cause or
another
no it is the highest and noblest lesson
of this great nation that all of you
will choose to die and suffer
to become nothing but cuts of American
meat
and there is only one escape from this
system
and this is I asked him
I remember that the knife slipped from
my shawl and clattered to the ground but
I did not pick it up
to be the one eating the meat
emotioned to his plate of cured pork fat
this pig
well this was a well-bred one from a
good family
a little piglet who knew his letters
you knew him well
won't you have a bite
I have some molasses to sweeten the
taste
and I cannot describe how it happened
as if a light suddenly Shone against his
face
I saw what he was
something
monstrously old
a weeping Red symbol was carved on his
forehead
and when he stretched his hands out
white staring eyes were set in his palms
I shrieked and ran
all he did was laugh and snort and
snuffle him like a pig
may I please finish this interview later
I don't feel well
no I I can continue speaking just just
some water please
you know about the pigment
how they burst out of our Shanty
slaughtering every man
and woman and child
I saw more die from the Stampede and the
crush than the creature's hands
though the ones who did die cut open to
Earth more of those hideous hideous
things
I will pray for from now on till the
hour of my death
Thomas and I hid until the Stampede of
men and Swine passed and joined a
handful of others
frankowitz and his friends who claimed
to know where kazewski's stockpile of
dynamite was
the old man was hauled up in the factory
they said
we would go in and
now what the plan was I cannot guess
two of them they
they were taken by those things before
we got there
women I had shared meals with
torn open with meat hooks
all to get our hands on a pistol and
three sticks of dynamite
but we took them
and headed back towards the factory
this place was still where we had made
our home after all
and we had no intention of seeing those
things
Slaughter us to a man
those Pig creatures were ferocious but
slow-witted
now that the crowd had escaped or had
been slaughtered
navigating around them was easier than
it seemed
though we were almost given away when
the sight of hanging bodies or trampled
children or worse
made us sick
no I can go on just some more water and
a cigarette
thank you
yes
you must have seen how the old man or
those creatures that hung the factory
walls with bodies
each one cut open
earthing screaming pigs onto the ground
the building itself straining and
shaking and panels from the roof
clattering to the ground
the noise gave us cover until the
handful of us found our way towards its
Center where the old man had cleared a
circle in the blood in the film
before one of the pillars where he had
hung some Idol he was bowing and
chanting
it was a word I do not know
I will try to say it
aeon
the old man spotted my husband first
his expression was one of baffelman
I truly do not think he can understand
why anyone would stand against him
but with a flick of his hand
faster than Thomas could pull the
trigger
I looked away just in time but in the
corner of my eye I saw him tearing apart
like old cloth
we scattered
and I grabbed the dynamite in matches
franckowitz threw the pistol but a pig
creature took all six shots with its
body
and close the distance with him
and plunged to meet up
where I found the strength I do not know
but I lit a match and touched it to the
dynamite and tossed it
it landed by the pillar some distance
from him
and he only laughed
nothing but meat I remember him saying
as he pointed his hand towards me
and then the dynamite exploded
and the pillar Twisted at its base
and the roof tore and buckled and I
brought the entire ceiling of
the factory down on that creature's head
[Music]
the Bureau of Investigation publicized a
cover story that the scp-7115 event was
caused by mass hysteria amongst workers
Molson and Company was dissolved in 1909
following the scp-7115 event H.H Molson
died in a car accident the same year an
event heavily rumored to have been
the Chicago Daily Courier having lost
its most prominent corporate backer as a
result likewise ceased operations in
1913. to obscure her involvement in the
event Jelena petrulis was indicted for
criminal damage of property dying due to
complications of pneumonia in prison in
1914.
due to the cessation of life functions
in all
scp-7115-1 instances
scp-7115-a is presumed neutralized
However the fact that a non-anomalous
human was able to survive the factory
buildings collapse suggests the
possibility of the Anthony's continued
survival
okay
I think that about does it for today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you're all dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaron
bake sip
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
segnor your local Foundation agent
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Dean dingus
that loser
casadia cams
braided Peach
GM's right
Rowan O'Brien
cake neck
Grim near extra moments one two three
and Swift Raw
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
[Music]